اذا قلت لكم تخيلوا لاعب كره قدم غالبا
اول صوره
لكريستيانو رونالدو او ميسي واذا قلت لكم
تخيلوا صوره لمبرمج على الاغلب راح تخيل
شخص مباراه قعدوا للابتوب اكواد طيب اذا
قلت لكم تخيلوا شخص كفيف شو ممكن تتخيلوه
ممكن ظلام او ممكن شخص حاط نظارات سود
وماسك عصايه البيضاء وفي حدا عم يساعده لا
يقدر يشارك بصراحه هاي الصوره المعتاده عن
المكفوفين هذا الشخص الكثيف بعد ما اضع
الشارع كان
عنده الشركات بس
ما بيشوف قوه
[موسيقى]
جرب مره ومرتين وثلاثه وعشره وكلهم رفضوا
راح على معهد بس اي مهارات رح يضل حتى
الناس بالشارع عم تقول له ليش ماشي لحالك
خليك بالبيت بلا ما
تتعصبق شهاده
بيجرب وبيتعلم لحد ما وصل على مسرح
سليمان
مبدئيا خلينا نعرف الشخص الكبير فبحصل
تعريف النظام الصحه العالميه
تصنيف الاول الكفيل في الجسم وهذا الشخص
البصر عنده وتتراوح الى 35 بالمئه تصنيف
الثاني
عنده اقل من 10% تصنيف الثالث اللي هو
الكفي في الكليه وبتكون صفر
بلشت قصتي بال 2015 وتحديدا لما انتقلت
على المكفوفين المدرسه الصغيره يلي فينا
نسميها مجتمع ذوي عقل بصريه بعد ما فقدت
95% من بصري صرت تشوف الاشياء كمجسمات
وصدار بدون
[موسيقى]
بحياتي ما بتخيلها انها موجوده اسلوب حياه
مختلف اشخاص عجيبه بطريقه ما كنت تعود
عليها اول ما المدرسه شفت بنت صغيره ما
بتشوف حتى اذا عم تمشي مع خطوه بخطوه لحد
ما وصلت عباءه صفه وفاتت هذا المشهد كان
بالنسبه لي جديد وغريب او حتى مؤثر ومع
الوقت المجتمع اكثر واكثر قديش هدول
الاشخاص مصدومين مظلومين بالافكار الغلط
[موسيقى]
تقرير الامم المتحده من بين العشر اشخاص
مكفوفين
والاربعين عم يشتغلوا
على الهاتف ومن بين عشره
[موسيقى]
على شركات لاحصل على فرصه عمل بمجالي
كصانع محتوى قدمت على ما يقارب 40 شركه
خلال شهور
كتير منهم تعالوا نطلبوا مني اعمل لهم
فيديو صغير تجريبي وبعد ما عمل فيديو اغلب
الشركات كان اللي الخبره المطلوبه ويحددوا
معي موعد للمقابله وبس يعرفوا انه كفيل
فجاه بيتغير كل شيء وبيرفضوني احد الشركات
المقدم عليهم وانا ورايحه المقابله وحمل
عصايه المكفوفين بايدي
[موسيقى]
وصار يقولوا
واحد منهم لعندي وقال لي انت شو
أهم
بس طبعا ما صدقت حط بايدي 100 ليره وطلع
ميدو مواقف صايره معي ومع رفقاتي
[موسيقى]
عن المكفوفين
تدور على المهارات بدها روميو ويتعلمون
وبعد ما اتعلمها انقلها للرفقات المكفوفين
هدفها بالكين المكفوفين من دخول سوق العمل
صرت احكي انشروا وحي الناس بكل مكان عن
الصوره
الغلطين كان بدي العب رياضه قالولي رياضه
واليوم انا بطل سوريا
للرياضه كنت بدي اتعلم الرسم
الرسم واليوم انا مصمم بدي اتعلم التصوير
والاخراج وصناعه المحتوى قالوا لي هاي
الامور بعيده عنها بلا
صانع محتوى
حصلت على جائزه افضل صانع محتوى للحد من
العنف في سوريا بعد الفتره حصلت على منحه
المليونير العربي القادم من حكميه
الامارات العربيه
وانا كنت الكفيف الوحيد من بين 20 الف شخص
ما دام على هاي المنحه بالوطن العربي
مسيرتي هاي دربت انا وفريقي اكثر من 100
مكفوف ومكفوفه
هل محتاجه بصل على مهارات تسبلوهم انهم
مستحيل يقدروا يتعلموها مثل التصوير
المونتاج صناعه المحتوى والبرمجه وغيره
اكيد راح تسالوني هلا بتعلم اي مهارات راح
اعرض عليكم فيديو
[موسيقى]
بالمناسبه هذا الفيديو الفريق من
المكفوفين كله
باحد التدريبات الامام لما جربنا نجمع
مجموعه من المكفوفين والصم بمكان واحد
لانه
التدريب المميز اخترنا مكان التدريب يكون
مزرعه بحيث نتعلم ونتسلى بنفس الوقت
وكان يوم مليان المواطن الصريفه اخذ لي
المواقف لما كانوا في قاعدين جنب المسبح
عم ياكلوا
وكان في شخص اصلا بمصلحه عم يغرق ويروح
يساعدوني بس طبعا مو منتبهين والامور عنده
م الحمد لله والاخير اجى حدا من اصدقائه
الصمت وساعده ونحن ثاني يوم نعرف قصه
التدريب كان مميز لدرجه الاشاره بمساعده
المترجم ونحن علمناهم
البصر عندي هي نفسها ممكن تكون قليله بس
لو كانت اكثر يمكن مجتمع صغير نانسي او
مصدوم يمكن ما كنت عرفت انه مالك ومحمود
وزين و50 الف كفيل سوري واكثر سعود 30
مليون كفيف حول العالم كنا الاشخاص
طبيعيين وقادرين عندهم شغله اقل ويا البصر
[موسيقى]
ويحقق التغيير مثل ما انا الخمسه
تغير الصوره السلبيه السلبيه عن المكفوفين
صوره حتى المجتمع بمجرد
وحتى من دون ما يتعامل معهم بمجرد انه
فاقدين والبصر
الوحيد لتحديد الامكانيات والقدرات
وهلا اذا قلت لكم تخيلوا شخص كفيف شو ممكن
تخيلوا ممكن الظلام او ممكن
في حدا عم يساعده
بصراحه هي الصوره المعتاده المكفوفين من
الناس اللي برا قاعده
اسدكم
[موسيقى]
وتكونوا سندهم وتضلوا اللي بينور طريقهم
شكرا
[تصفيق]